let's say that we've got the equation 2x
minus 1 times X plus 4 is equal to 0
pause this video and see if you can
figure out the x values that would
satisfy this equation or essentially our
solutions to this equation
alright now let's work through this
together so at first you might be
tempted to multiply these things out or
there's multiple ways that you might
have tried to approach it but the key
realization here is that you have two
things being multiplied and it's being
equal to 0 so you have the first thing
being multiplied is 2x minus 1 this
expression is being multiplied by X plus
4 and to get it to be equal to 0 1 or
both of these expressions needs to be
equal to 0 let me really reinforce that
idea if I had two variables let's say a
and B and I told you a times B is equal
to 0 well can you get the product of two
numbers to equal 0 without at least one
of them being equal to 0 and the simple
answer is no if a is 7 the only way that
you would get 0 is if B is 0 or if B was
5 the only way to get zeros if a is 0 so
you see from this example either let me
write this down either A or B or both
because 0 times 0 is 0 or both must be 0
the only way that you get the product of
two quantities and you get 0 is if one
or both of them is equal to 0 I really
want to reinforce this idea I'm going to
put a I'm gonna put a red box around it
so that it really get stuck in your
brain I want you to think about why that
is try to come up with two numbers try
to multiply them so that you get zero
and you're going to see that one of
those numbers is going to need to be is
going to need to be 0 so we're going to
use this idea right over here
now this might look a little bit
but you could view 2x minus 1 as our a
and you could view X plus 4 as our B so
either 2x minus 1 needs to be equal to 0
or X plus 4 needs to be equal to 0 or
both of them needs to be equal to 0 so I
could write that as 2 X minus 1 needs to
be equal to 0
or or X plus 4 or X let me do that
Orange
actually let me do the 2 X minus 1 in
that yellow color so either 2x minus 1
is equal to 0 or X plus 4 is equal to 0
X plus 4 is equal to 0 and so let's
solve each of these
if 2x minus 1 could be equal to 0 well
see you could add 1 to both sides and we
get 2x is equal to 1 divide both sides
by 2 and this is just straightforward
solving a linear equation if this looks
unfamiliar I encourage you to watch
videos on solving linear equations on
Khan Academy but you'll get X is equal
to 1/2 as one solution this is
interesting because we're going to have
two solutions here or over here if we
want to solve for X we can subtract 4
from both sides and we would get X is
equal to negative 4 so it's a need in an
equation like this you can actually have
two solutions X could be equal to 1/2 or
X could be equal to negative 4
I think it's pretty interesting to into
substitute either one of these in if X
is equal to 1/2 what is going to happen
well this is going to be 2 times 1/2
minus 1/2 times 1/2 minus 1 that's going
to be our first expression and that our
second expression is going to be 1/2
plus 4 and so what's this going to be
equal to well 2 times 1/2 is 1 1 minus 1
is 0 so I don't care what you have over
here 0 times anything is going to be
equal to 0 so when what x equals 1/2
the first thing becomes 0
making everything making the product
equal zero and likewise if x equals
negative four it's pretty clear that
this second expression is going to be
zero and even though this first
expression isn't going to be zero in
that case anything times zero is going
to be zero let's do one more example
here so let me delete out everything
that I just wrote here and so let's I'm
gonna involve a function so let's say
someone told you that f of X is equal to
X minus five times 5x plus two and
someone said find the zeros of f of X
well the zeros are what are the X values
that make f of X equal to zero when does
f of X equal zero for what for what X
values does f of X equal zero that's
what people are really asking when they
say find the zeros of f of X so to do
that well when does f of X equal zero
well f of X is equal to zero when this
expression right over here is equal to
zero and so it sets up just like the
equation we just saw X minus five times
5x plus 2 when does that equal zero and
like we said like we saw before this
says well this is just like what we saw
before and I encourage you to pause the
video and try to work it out on your own
so there's two situations where this
could happen where either the first the
first expression equals zero or the
second expression or maybe in some cases
you'll have a situation where both
expressions equal zero so we could say
either X minus five is equal to zero or
5x plus two is equal to zero I'll write
in or right over here now if we solve
for X you add five to both sides of this
equation you get X is equal to five here
let's see to solve for X you can
subtract two from both sides you get 5x
is equal to negative two you can divide
both sides by five to solve for x
and you get X is equal to negative
two-fifths so here are our two zeros you
input either one of these into f of X if
you input X equals five if you take F of
five if you try to evaluate F of five
then this first expression is going to
be zero and so a product of zero and
something else it doesn't matter that
this is going to be twenty seven zero
times 27 is zero and if you take F of
negative two-fifths it doesn't matter
what this first expression is the second
expression right over here is going to
be zero zero times anything is zero